primero tenemos que entender el formato
novedoso como muy bien lo presentan y al
final no dejó de ser un arte exacto
televisivo muy eficaz e incluso el hecho
que eva longoria una conocida actriz
fuera la moderadora de la presentadora
también nos dice lo que se quiere lograr
por medio de este de este formato pero
al final también fue carente de
espontaneidad el mismo hecho de ser algo
como el natal le quita esa espontaneidad
respecto a lo que a lo que puede darse
en persona pero también creo que la
carencia de planes versus el ataque a
donald trump creo que es una
manifestación misma de lo que espera el
primer día y creo que no va a cambiar en
el resto de los días de aquí al jueves
que termina la convención escuchamos
previamente en el informe el discurso de
michelle obama no que es considerado
como uno de los más encendidos de esta
jornada ataco bastante al presidente de
donante mente en otras cosas dijo
textualmente que trump
el presidente equivocado para el país
que ha tenido tiempo más que suficiente
para demostrar que puede hacer el
trabajo pero que está claramente
superado ese tiempo y que no puede
enfrentar este momento qué rol cree
usted que tiene michelle obama en estos
comicios y como evalúa su influencia en
el electorado
bueno déjame decirte que quiera que no
para los demócratas michelle obama tiene
una una influencia y por eso la están
usando el hecho que tenga el cierre de
la primera noche le da un papel
preponderante la quieren
usar justamente para eso es un papel que
ya dejó siendo la primera dama que le da
ese lugar a ella
y obviamente lo utilizó de esa manera
incluso abriendo su corazón pero a
partir de un ataque de diciéndole que el
presidente actual no no es el adecuado y
la usan creo yo para para ese propósito